any guy
who goes after a girl significantly
younger than them is severely lacking in
their life and I I mean that confidence
wise I mean like they are falling short
in so many places that that is the only
place they can turn to to feel like they
have they have something on the scale of
power and it's I mean ultimately it's
predatory I mean there's just no way to
kind of because you're manipulating
someone who is not aware of what they're
giving you and it's unfair
so my question is why are men called
Predators for going for younger women
but women don't typically have that same
energy for women that go for younger men
I don't know because I think older women
also prejudices honestly like if you're
dating someone that much younger they
have way less life experience they don't
know themselves as well like you know
how to like shape them like you know to
get them way easier what would you put
at Predator like what what's your what's
the age Gap that you would say Predator
is Kruger
it's a lesson negative word I don't know
maybe
15 20 years 15 20 years and would you
say the age Gap um does it matter how
old the younger person is like if
they're 30 yes yes it does not matter if
that if I think if that under like 25 or
if they're under 25 or like under 27
maybe yeah okay and then it's like 20
years yeah Prejudice is the wrong word
Predator is a yeah
Predator is the wrong word and should
never be used Predator is the word you
use when you're going after
yeah miners you are yeah you're you know
it isn't being predated as someone that
has kind of power over you no no no a
predator is someone who is seeking out
to do harm so whether where there are
adults who seek to do harm in a certain
way which I'll you know we can't stay on
here to children that is what is called
a predator a predator is not what was
described in that video if you were a
man of any age whether you were going
after a male or female child intending
to meet them to do what you're going to
do that is a predator so on that video
Predator is the wrong word and it's
taken out of context and it of course
it's going to blow up on social media
and people are going to start people are
influenced by people like her and you're
going to start every time you see some a
couple out on the street or in a bar
you're going to turn around oh he's a
predator or she's a predator because
you've heard it on social media it's the
wrong word if you want to know what a
predator is
yeah it's definitely not that I don't
know if you're underage it's not
consensual if it's between two
consensual adults
must have a bit more intention than that
but I think she's saying I don't know I
don't know what you're saying because
I'm just thinking over the case like
you're you're 18 you have the same
rights that I do if you want to jump in
a car right now you can go do it if you
want to vote you can vote like we're
both adults you know I mean if if we're
talking about under 16 and all them type
of things then we can talk about a
different story but I I think it's uh
like like um miscellaneous front said
you know I think Predators using the
wrong sensor I think we I'm sorry but my
real my real question is I I don't see
the same energy for women yeah I mean
even even when you started they're like
okay but it's like on social media if a
man says I I like a girl that's
significantly younger he's shamed for it
but women aren't I agree yeah
um it is a bit I'm not gonna lie though
I think that in a girl's world if you're
dating a guy that is younger than you
you are a sometimes can be looked as a
bit weird like why are you going for
like those younger the news now why not
no I'm just saying that's how it is
usually in the girls world and I think
that the difference stems from the
intentions as well usually I would say
correct me if I'm wrong I think
generally a man that goes for woman that
is younger it'll be for those reasons of
like okay she's less combative she's
um you know easier to mold and all these
things fine is that right wait whereas
if you're a woman and you're going for a
younger guy a lot of the time I feel it
might be for the energy in the future
appreciation now they've got a whole
woman so I think like I think that the
intentions may be slightly different and
that's why I mean what they're getting
at and I think they're probably talking
from experience you can tell the look in
their eyes when you're when you're a
young woman especially if you're a
pretty young woman a lot of older men
will approach you and at that moment in
time when you're that age there's a lot
of things that you really just don't
know in fact you don't even know enough
about men to be able to navigate the
world with these sort of men after you
so that's why they would
use such a strong word to describe it
because actually at the end of the day
it is a little bit twisted what about a
girl that what is it
but why don't we have that same energy
of young women that go after older men
for their money
predator
would you say that Leonardo DiCaprio I
would argue yeah
no no he just hit me look it what do
they say that though
no the economy is so bad that you have
Leonardo DiCaprio dating 27 years old
it's crazy I asked the woman who got for
a young man so it's wrong for let's say
it's wrong for men in their 30s to go
for 18 year olds I understand why they
would like the the submissive um being
cooperative and like less bodies but why
would an older woman in their like 30s
go for a guy who is like 20 like what
seven minutes what benefits do you get
from going from there it's just just the
stamina that's it do you not want I'm
the girls that actually go for younger
men I do not want a man that can provide
and be like a proper leader I know there
are some younger guys but generally
speaking men men under 30 they can't
really give you what you want so I just
want to know what I would say they love
you way harder if they're younger
because you're more likely to be there
one of their first loves you know I mean
like I think as they are older the love
gets a little bit more like I've done
this a thousand times like well and it's
kind of I mean it's kind of a meeting
strategy in a way because it's like men
have less sexual Capital when they're
younger and then women have less sexual
Capital when they're older so they kind
of hit off each other yeah and don't
forget also what the boy said earlier
they're like oh yeah she was so much
more mature and she was this and yeah I
enjoyed it and this so they appreciated
her that's it so it's nice yeah but
what's the what's the woman gaining I
get them what the man you get validated
yeah we like nice words we just want a
man to appreciate us
um no that's why don't forget that women
also went and they require a lot of
validation so sometimes when you go for
younger Monday he's able to give you
that but all these guys have just said
that they're only looking to like not
really like a long commitment with an
older woman because she has like too
much baggage and all of that so like
what is the older women getting out of
this if it's not just fine like if it's
if she's looking for a long time
commitment like what is she finding with
these young men that don't want a long
time coming with an older woman yeah
would you say it's more companionship
yeah because so I'm gonna ask you
because you actually date younger man
um yeah it's companionship and I won't
judge a young man my I've said it
already earlier on my ex was a lot
younger than me and age was totally
irrelevant
um you there are some gaps there are
things that he won't know and I won't
know and then somewhere you sort of just
meet in the middle but you get
companionship you you know I I was in
love we were I could say we were
genuinely in love you know I'm not going
to talk about the reasons we broke up
but yeah we were together four years and
that was with someone younger than me I
had companionship I had friendship I had
someone that understood me I had love I
had someone that looked out for me he
was actually a great cook
um I'm a bit lazy at that
um you know I used to go over to his
home and there was always food food
waiting for me not because I couldn't
you know go in the kitchen and make
something it was a real relationship so
everyone experiences something different
I think we've just got too many
stereotypes is oh you can't go out with
a younger man or you can't go out with
someone old man so you might tell me oh
I can't go out with someone that's 60 or
70. but what happens you know if I'm
attracted they're a nice man the
relationship is nice they're a good
person to me yeah the companionship is a
big word so to me it doesn't really
matter you have to it's something that
we all said here before you have to and
you said it particularly it it depends
on the actual person so if I'm gonna
have a relationship I mean I don't want
a fling I don't want to be
I don't want to be with a man that's
just going to fling his bits around
um to put it politely it doesn't matter
how old you are obviously we all have
age restrictions but if I like you we're
attracted you respect me
you know you have love for me you're my
friend you're my companion you look out
for me you're a man you're a man you're
a leader you know how to look after me
it doesn't really matter if you've got
all those qualities
I'm Gonna Be With You
how no never mind the age some people I
know that men's I think mature a little
bit later we will know that but what
happens when there's those individuals
who are the right one for you
I just have a question now like yeah of
course um you know obviously you think
that way no when he was like in your
late
um late 20s or like early 30s did you
think the same way like would you still
look for like a younger guy in that same
companionship role or you is this a
recent thing where you decided no no
nothing nothing is recent My Views have
never changed
um just a man has to be a good man
someone that wants to
look after me but can I just ask would
you seek out a younger man actively
actively actively know but if one
crossed my path and they happen to be
you know let's say I'm just going to
throw a number out here if one crossed
my path and all of a sudden I met them
and and they I said how old were you and
they told me let's say for example
between 25 and 30 I'm not all of a
sudden I'm gonna turn around and say I'm
sorry I can't date you because your age
they might be the right person for me
yeah fair enough what about like an 18
year old like if you were just out there
on an 18 year old couch and was like oh
you're a beautiful woman so so there's a
hard cap too yeah there is no I wouldn't
okay no no it's kind of interesting
because you kind of contradict yourself
yeah no I understand I understand I
understand what you mean and talk about
contradictions so we all have age limits
and we've all talked about it here
tonight and whilst I'm talking about yes
I will date a younger man I still have
my limit so I don't think that's me
contradicting myself I'm saying yes I'll
date it younger man but I'm capping a
limit just like everybody else so I
don't think that I'm I'm being
contradictory
I just wanna
excuse me I just want to add
um so
um in terms of my experience with women
yeah
I've never actually been in a
relationship with a woman that's younger
than me
and um what I
hearing these discussions for me to the
two key words of the two takeaways are
you for maturity I think it goes in both
directions
um so I think for me I I presented
myself
as being a lot more older than I then I
guess in terms like the barometer of men
my age
and that's sort of what a lot of women
responded to and then once I'd
filled my age
in comparison to the the age that they
had the mental image that they had of me
it sort of I don't know just sort of
made something inside them just go a bit
I don't know
um a bit addicted to me in a certain way
um
so I just think I think it goes both
ways because you're saying earlier about
the 18 year olds and the 32.
maturity doesn't necessarily have a
fixed age if someone carries themselves
as like a 25 year old or 42 year old and
stuff more often than not weak kind of
like connect with that as opposed to
checking people's ID cards so
um that was just my my takeaway for that
it's all what society and people around
us say is the right thing to do it's
it's it's almost like saying I can't be
your friend unless you eat chalk mint
chocolate
you know everyone has to eat meat mint
chocolate if you want to be connected to
me because that's what Society that's
what the news tell us to do that's what
social media tells us to do that's what
your friends are telling you to do how
about what you want to do and how
sitting down with yourself and thinking
actually is this right does it work is
that the right person for me or am I
only doing what Society
expect me to do have you ever had
someone
um do you typically not tell people your
age when you meet them like guys you're
talking to or interested in
um guys that I'm talking to
um they're dating whatever yeah well I
mean I'm I've been single for a couple
years by choice because I'm not I'm not
gonna just go out there and date anyone
and just for the sake of it
um once I start talking to someone yeah
we do we do discuss ages and backgrounds
and okay so you you tell them up front
yeah okay I wasn't sure has anyone ever
rejected you because of your age
instead of do they know before the date
oh oh always yeah I think the only time
you get rejected is sometimes based on
Color Race religion culture those are
the things when all of a sudden things
change but age no I've never had a
problem with that I have actually been
rejected because of my age so I just
think like age is also equal to like
raise color like same version and stuff
I've met older guys and then they find
out that I am I like the other thing
about 18 19 20 whatever and they were
like Oh no you're too young so I think
it's very it's just very circumstantial
but the probability when you're younger
that you're not gonna match with someone
about older than
likely like I think with the mint
chocolate like like concept you're more
likely to like a mint chocolate that's
your own age you know I mean because
you're in the same stage of life more
likely but obviously there's going to be
those people those outliers that that
are that do match you have
um have any raise your hand other the
guys has a girl ever told you that
you're too young for her
ever
interesting okay I was just curious
when you asking that question are you
talking about now when we were younger
because ever I mean yeah yeah yeah I
don't know I just feel like
yes there's exceptions to the rule like
the minimals the one percents all of
these things that is fantastic ideally
would work fantastically but I the way I
look at a relationship is that you're
both running the same race separately
and then that means that you're more
likely to be successful you're both
running the same race separately yeah
the same way that you say people are the
same but they're different the same
difference all that kind of thing
because this is like a parallel thing
and you're striving towards the same
goal which would be to raise a family to
obviously have a good relationship
together for the rest of your life
success blah blah blah blah and I think
it's much easier and I think it's more
you're more likely to succeed if you are
at similar stages and levels because
there's so much more understanding in
terms of even culture in terms of social
context and everything so I just think
you're more likely to be more successful
in that with somebody that is closer to
you in so many more areas what do you
think the number one swiped right age is
on dating apps for men and for women if
you've heard this on the show before
please don't ruin it what's the wall
what are you okay what do you think the
number one swipe right so like yes 22
ages for men and for women both yeah
over dating apps women is probably going
to be like 32 no I'll say 20 22 for
women no women
um
start here and then go around
um for men I probably think 24 25 for
women
um 40.
I think guys would pick like
23 girls 32.
um men men 20 women 30 35
so I think men are probably gonna pick
like
22 23 I think guys are probably gonna go
for like
oh wait wait am I saying like guys are
going for them
yeah so I think guys will be going for
like 25 year olds I think women are
going for like older like 28 29 because
they want the money yeah okay I think
most guys have money by 28 29.
[Laughter]
I think men are going for like probably
like 21 maybe even like 2019 and then
girls are going for like 26. okay uh
girls are going out say 22 20 no sorry
guys are going for women who are around
22 23 and I think women are going for
guys that are like 29 30.
I fit men are picking women
that are probably 22 23 and women are
going for guys
32 to 35.
me I think uh the men will go after the
girls who are
20 21 and then the girls are probably
going like 32 to be fair
yeah I'd say most swept women 22 most
swapped guys three
no one got it what is it I
actually really I didn't believe this
when I first saw it I I was shocked and
I'm I'm me you know
um the most swiped right age for a guy
um Did anyone say 40s anymore
it's actually older it's actually older
than that it's 50. wow
this was like uh plenty this is it
couldn't be 10. I don't know if it was
plenty I could look it up I don't I
don't know the exact app someone someone
put in the comments all right most
swiped right for girls
18. oh God
so all these guys want 18 year olds as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible